And, I would argue delta x is 2, so if we go down with, here in this axis,
one down in the y direction, then we go two to the right.
And, kind of orthogonally, as we go one to the right here, we go two up.
So, the delta y over here is also 2.
It turns out these two vectors again are orthogonal.
If you understand what a dot product is and
you did the dot product of these two vectors you will get zero which is a measure of orthogonality.
But that's not really that important.
What's important is that we found out where the center of the data is and
we found the principle axis of variation.
The only last thing I didn't tell you about, the only last thing is that PCA
also returns an importance value, a spread value for this axis.
An that spread value tends to be very large for the very first axis of variation
and much smaller for the second axis of variation if the spread is small.
So this number is, happens to be an, an eigenvalue.
It comes out of an eigenvalue decomposition that's really implemented by PCA.
But what it really gives you is an importance vector,
how important to take each axis when you look at the data.
So when you run the code you'll find the new origin,
you find these different vectors and you'll find an importance value is given to
these vectors that really measures the amount of spread.
So let me do a little quiz here to see if we are at odds with each other.